you to want our tout le monde sait
squeeze on est sur la version elementary
je dois trouver des nounours euh je peux
courir je peux pas être un de la lampe
la vision est super chelou joue au moins
le sont dans mon cas ce mois-ci parti
alors on dirait une sorte de bâche
non ces désertions je la trouve belle
mais du coup vu comme un réflexe de
trouver des pages on est un peu dans le
caca faut bien le dire
alors je sais pas trop où on est ouah
leçon qui parle du genre dégagé parce
que vous êtes en danger
la co op tshikapa de mettre un nounours
à la poubelle non dommage
oh mon dieu qu'est-ce qu'une plante fait
est là lafferty chat potté co driver
gras qu'on m'explique alors est-ce qu'on
touche c'était comme ça c'était quoi ça
ok ya déjà des choses bizarres sens que
je n'ai rien demandé c'est la fenêtre
d'accord mon faut trouver des
dénouements c'est à d'accord en fait
c'est pas une plante à stains nounours
merde
c'était un honneur d or ce sont plein
plante donne ma faute
voilà du coup on a le bruit super
stressant attendait ouais y'a bien de
nous sommes allés chercher si je tombe
nez à nez avec l'autre là je je je lui
met une claque à une claque dans sa mère
là parce que j'en ai marre suffit quoi
votre paie nos films
il ya des traits horizontaux sur cette
version c'est pour ça que la vision est
un peu bizarre
si je regarde là où vous voyez moi je
pense que vous verrez sur la vidéo il ya
espèces d'autres horizons tôt ap
puis qu'est-ce qui fait déjà quatre noms
je veux pas déjà mourir là je refuse
joe starr au refus catégorique c'est à
dire que ce n'est pas possible
pour ce qui est des arbres [ __ ] saluer
tu viens voir il va bon on se casse
allez hop on bouge couleurs le kg pour
montrer mon mécontentement
j'en arrache du sang qui offraient de la
sauce tomate c'est moi oui tu sois tu
fais des tristes au [ __ ] hommes et le
niveau mais de deux lots de glos qui tue
d'un sabre a ouai bof tu veux mais qui a
trouvé un brave la pose et la tranquille
dans sa va pas renoncer sur des trucs
qu'on des murs après déjà trois le truc
qui est chiant c'est que plus on ne
ramasse plus adversaires
sonore oies les graphismes une tuerie
une tuerie retardé c'est quoi cette
jeune manon schick avait une jambe de
sender c'est pour vient de faire flipper
mais juste une jambe jeudi dépasse celle
du camp tu ailles le souk dessus je peux
à éponger avis bon en fait le gros souci
c'est qu'on a tellement peur qu'on
retient pas où on va seul gros problème
en vêtements pour ma part en tout cas
[Musique]
aller à lever je continue je coache lui
par contre il va rentrer d'entre eux va
nous faire du mal à avoir là c'est là
qu'on fait moins les malins petit rire
loeb
j'espère qu'il ya toujours moyen de
sortir on va s'est tendu à aulas est
très tendu un parce que là on fait le
tour mais lui aussi à faire tout et pas
cours
faudrait déjà de l'autre côté là bas là
je pense que j'ai tout fait mais est-ce
qu'on va tomber sur lui veut assez bon
les palais ali gti à l'amande poteau à
la corps à corps bouger sur la route je
ne sais pas comment à certaines heures
il peine plus peur en fait c'est en fait
c'est quoi le screamer et quand tu tombe
nez à nez avec lui je trouve que ces
versions là sont un peu trop clair en
fait sans faire le kéké ou quoique a pas
peur c'est pas que j'ai pas peur de ça
chauffe cache pas que j'ai peur c'est
que ça aurait pu être plus amusant avec
plus de moi c'est ce que je pense et
avec des nouilles aux plus humbles a
trouvé assez une école abbaoui la
montagne au sénégal ont fait une école
c'est une crèche tâche et je m'y colle
[Musique]
bon voilà c'est ça que j'aime pas c'est
soan merwe
le pleurer mais la disparue comme par
hasard le mal du coup j'ai pu dans mon
sens once d'or ont fait un choix
messieurs dames soit tombe à verse
länder soit on prend lé nounours
j'imagine bien de nos écrans au test
donc 1
ah [ __ ] reste bas c'est pour ça j'ai
cru que ça lui faisait peur en fait
c'est sega stranger qui zones grises des
as au [ __ ] faut deux versions bon on a
fait mieux sur celle d'avant on a fait
cet s'il vous plaît c'est tu manques et
une page
[ __ ] notre revanche tout de suite
dedans slider auspices let's grow up
papapapa hockey prend le chômage ya pas
de souci je me casse de la vase il ya
beau probasis et tout à toi tu prends la
dynamique et le tableau même cassé la
vie si tu veux pas casser un mur
vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y fais ce que tu
veux seulement